are you finding that with the people who
work with you are people
moving away and uh no no one has moved
no one in my organization has moved what
do you think of surely moving to alabama
i don't understand how it's gonna work
practically i mean uh
doesn't he need to be at the show in the
office
or are his duties mostly confined to
chasing wack packers around
well i guess what what the the issue is
is that we're not in our offices
everybody's working from home right like
your show so i guess his
right hand make a move to actually move
your family
is kind of a permanent thing unless
you're like well no we're
just staying there for a while and we're
going to move back but
that's a hell of a commute all right to
answer jimmy's question about
truly is shirley hello
good morning
i love that music it came down to uh an
issue
of just my family and i not being in a
safe area for my kids
and right and i know it's out of the way
and it's a far
commute my main way was
my family and so that's what i put we
didn't ask you that question we asked
you how are you going to
commute to work when we go back to the
studio i don't know i don't have that
answer right now neither do you neither
does howard
no that's true when you guys come back
in the city i'll come back in the city
absolutely well no it doesn't
necessarily work that way
i might never come back to the city but
the staff will okay well when we get to
that point
we'll figure it out right now my main
concern is my family
why wouldn't you have that figured out
before you move
no i haven't figured out robin what
you're not understanding is
i put my family safety first in the job
julie you get so defensive about this
it's just really we're just asking i
mean in all fairness guys like you
you're not living where i was living
but you moved a thousand miles away i
mean they're probably places like maybe
40 miles away or
i mean like new jersey or westchester
right we all found places pretty close
that were sick
there are seven other states between new
york and alabama
uh none of those states appealed to you
it was alabama
there's nothing safe between here and
there julie was there any part of you
that thought
what's the funniest place i could move
to and then you came up with alabama
that was a factor do you know something
about this virus that we don't
is this i mean really truly said the
other day on the year that alabama is a
hot spot for comedy
and uh i didn't understand it but
explain it to jimmy he'll he'll
understand
i never said the word i never said the
word i said there's still opportunities
out here for comedy it doesn't
it's not like comedy hasn't reached
alabama yes gary you wanted to add
howard i know you don't want to go down
the rabbit hole so i'll just do it for
you benji
is now claiming for real that if the
show never comes back he or
you know where he you can live wherever
you want he's going to tel aviv because
there the show starts at 2pm